so my name is daniel barber I'm a PhD
candidate here at Columbia in
architecture and I'll be introducing our
third panel of the day and second to
last panel of this fabulous two day
event under the title of scales of
reconfiguration City region and state so
i just want to point out a few very
broad sort of framing issues as is the
custom to introduce the panel and then
again has been the custom go introduce
everybody one by one and let them come
up and give their papers so the for the
only first sort of thing i want to point
out is is that our title recalls and
somewhat inverts right the discourse on
Patrick Geddes 1909 Valley section as it
was sort of resuscitated in the 50s by
team ten and I think of course team 10
has been relative to this question of
kind of state activity has been part of
our discussions all along so first in
the door in manifesto in 54 and then at
cm10 this valley section in which the
scales of association right were
intended to produce new criteria for
urban and rural integration and also new
opportunities for building design and
again we saw some of this especially
last night in Mark Ronson's fascinating
lecture so if we can all sort of imagine
right this this collectively sort of
project the team 10 version of the
scales of association onto the screen
here and I'll just talk about it for one
second most of you know we're most
familiar perhaps with the smiths ins
version of it is presented at Dubrovnik
which traces a valley following gettys
initial drawing traces of valley from
the isolate up at the top for the
village to the town and to the city
right so this sort of V shape that then
goes back up from city to town to
village and the Smithson Smith sends
imperative in this regard as again one
of the sort of founding moments of team
ten to develop as they as they put it
working parties to operate in a field
rather than a point right so to approach
this drawing is a sort of imperative to
develop a new way of engaging questions
of city and region in town and really a
field of architectural operation as we
know the sort of familiar story of this
the transformation men of the four sort
of points of the Athens charter into the
scales of association so what's
interesting for us here is that what was
forget ease a diagram of a sort of
changing distribution of labor right
according to the process of
industrialization as it was occurring
surrounding the turn of the century is
for Team 10 it's mrs. in particular sort
of redistribution of operative fields
right so it's a question of sort of
registry reconfiguring the labor of
architecture in that regard articulating
new design opportunities according to
the familiar tropes of the post-war
discussions of habitats of and as you
get as we saw last night the men on the
street everyday life etc more sort of
loops I always forgets me emphasize an
interrogation of relationships between
these type illogical proposals of
modernist urbanism of the problematics
of density and circulate circulation and
the multi-faceted engagement with
anthropological and social scientific
models right all on the table for this
reconfiguration in the 1950s o our
inversion of this team ten
interpretation are sort of 2010
intervention into the 1954
interpretation right of this 1909
original drawing an attempt to see the
discourse of the 50s and again we're not
discussing team ten in particular here
but sort of using it as a jumping-off
point see the discourse of the 50s as
something of a symptomatic response to
some issues that we will see in this
panel which is a more direct and sort of
explicit engagement with infrastructure
so which is to say rather than the
fields themselves sort of the
transversal cuts across these various
fields scales of association into the
question of the architectural parameters
in the challenge to them presented by
the infrastructural scale so that's to
say again
that we can recognize in this sort of
imperative taken from the Smith since
taken sort of against the Smith sins
that recognizing the patterns of
association of architectural planning
and policy practices that lead to or
participate in these various
ossification of infrastructural networks
and through that perhaps both sort of
producing and limiting forms of life
right producing and limiting new ways of
existing in this so-called modernized
condition in other words the state back
to our sort of initial theme the state
is either entity or Mirage perhaps as a
component of the production of
subjectivity comes to be constructed and
even produced as a consequence of these
ossification right of these sort of
architectural / infrastructural
interventions and at the same time how
infrastructure as a sort of tantalizing
combination for the design fields a
complicating as we'll see in these
papers in various ways economics
technology population management and
even you know perhaps aesthetics in this
sense is sort of this tantalizing a
vacation right this this process of
interpolating architectural practices in
both the formation of the state and the
formation of subjectivity so in this
sense while we might anticipate that by
both broadening our scale right sort of
taking a broad scale as our object and
also by emphasizing the scale itself
right that the role of the state is a
political entity might sort of come into
a different set of resolutions perhaps
even be clarified well we find that
thankfully this is not really the case
but rather than by insisting on scales
of operations we sort of burrow further
into the problematics of state practices
and design culture as we'll see played
out in a number of very interesting
developments through the three papers
this afternoon okay so with that sort of
general framing mechanism I'll introduce
the three speakers again in order and
then let them come up and make their
presentation our first speaker is Arturo
al Mondo's a professor of architecture
at the Universidad Simon Bolivar in
Caracas and at the Universidad catlica
de Chile in Santiago he's the author of
numerous books
articles including herbin is minus Rho
pale in Caracas excuse me eighteen
seventeen nineteen forty I won't try the
numbers an editor of planning Latin
America's capital cities 1852 1950 his
paper today will be showcases of
development state urban modernism and
regional planning in Latin America in
1930s to 1950s our next speaker will be
Joe el jefe el santhosh lecturer and PhD
candidate at the faculty the architect
puta at the University dodgy technique
Hadleys bow he will present the paper
there we go the infrastructural
metropolis Lisbon 1904 to 1967 and
finally we will hear from Z Efrat the
director of the School of Architecture
at the bezalel academy of arts and
design in Jerusalem and partner in
ephrata Kowalski architects the title of
his paper the architectural fabrication
of Israel so if you'll join me in
welcoming all three of our speed thank
you well i would like to start by
thanking the organizers of the event
which has been very reward and indeed
and also by well letting you know that
this is a paper drawn from our research
line that i have developed as is called
modern say order modernization of latin
america from the midnight 19th century
through the mid 20th century and today
i'm going to focus on are on an episode
about what I have called showcases of
development in which I will try to sort
of contextualize modernism Oh modernise
more in relation to the processes of
urbanization industrialization on
development ilysm all day savages mo
from a panoramic and comparative
perspective the paper aims at explaining
the relationships between some of Latin
America's are nationalists and corporate
states under urban and territorial
expressions in the golden
age of the region's development policy
and modernization two main streams will
allow our decorating so to speak this
spatial showcases of the server gizmo
I'm not sure whether the term for the
savages with developmental ism but
anyway it I this is the policies that I
will try to use firstly I emphasizing
firstly the transition from the European
oriented and academic design of the
first urban plans to the definite
adoption of functional modernism by the
1940s and secondly the incorporation of
a mainly north american oriented
technique of planning on a regional
scale the first section I'm going to
focus on is is I call it a neither
development no modernization and I'm
trying just to to do that initial
contextualization of the process that I
think is very it could be interested by
the late by the 1920s Latin America's
biggest countries boasted to citizens /
H peasant that had remained in the
backward pampers genres or said tones of
their vast countryside this is of course
a gross indicator that camouflages are
sharply contrasted reality as most of it
has to do with this continent in which
art in which Argentina and the Southern
Cone are had more than fifty percent of
its population urbanized since nineteen
fourteen well as Andean or Central
American countries were predominantly
rural until the mid until the 1950s in a
few decades of the 20th century Latin
American countries completed a cycle
that had taken more than 100 years in
Britain and other nations that
industrialized and urbanized throughout
the 19th century and this is why i have
included this arm sort of comparison
here of the of their curves of of
organization involved industrialized and
third world countries up in the nineteen
and twenty century as a sort of very
simplified comparison of the demographic
transition
cycle as well from the end of the second
world war until the mid-1960s Latin
America's biggest countries showed a
relative prosperity marked by
significant economic expansion amid
sustained organisation fueled by the
massive markets targeted by the import
substitution industrialization or is I
Brazil and Mexico reach a yearly growth
of six percent what may them appear by
the 1950s and 1960s respectively as
model economies of the so-called taken
off towards development in terms of
course of Walt Whitman roscoes famous
arm our theory of development which was
very much very much in fashion by then
in Latin America among political and
economic arm melius the modernizing
climate our was promoted and I have also
included just a general image of for
instance the booming are a growth of
buenos aires by the late 1930s with
major words in a vanilla image oh and so
forth the modernizing climate was
penetrated by an economic nationalism
that was shared with a heterodoxy by
Latin America's our socialism and
liberalism democracies and dictatorships
alive it ranged from the populace
regimes of Mexico's lzaro crdenas
Argentina's fund eberron unruh seals
Ditullio vargas to the progressive yet
brutal dictatorships of kubas Cuba's
Fulgencio Batista and Venezuela's marcos
perez jimenez their common agenda of the
Suraj eastman was back since nineteen
forty eight by the creation of
international agencies such as the
Organization of American States the OS
and the economic commission for latin
america you know whether it's a gorilla
above the sponsor by the United Nations
and the USS are growing interest in
regions primary and industrial
exploitation and of course our cause and
a claw were very much in favor of
bolstering this program of the savage
yzma by those years while being um well
being regarded as promising example
developing countries a category that
seemed to have great resonance until the
1960s most of Latin America's
industrialization societies seem to be
exponent of the classic theory of
modernization as it was explained by the
models of economic growth and functional
sociology from the early 60s the
connection between industrialization
urbanization and modernization was
formulated following an almost cows
whole derivation by Leona Raisman and
Kingsley Davis for instance from the
standpoint of social change and
demographic transition relying on
examples of the North Atlantic countries
that had industrialized in the 19th
century from that literature could be
the news that Latin America's developing
nations appear to be in the path towards
urbanization and urbanization and
industrialization but they actually
suffer from profound distortions by
comparison with successful experiences
of modernization in Europe North America
and all the parts of the world as it was
started buying say for instance by our
phillip house' in the early 1960s
distortions or differences could be
gathering two groups on the one hand a
fledgling industrialization had not
proceeded but rather followed
organisation in latin america so the ISI
was not the equivalent of an industrial
revolution with its dynamic effects on
the economic system and demographic
transition on the other hand levels of
organization almost double industrial
participation in the economies of
Argentina Chile Venezuela Colombia and
Brazil according to 1950s censuses in
the decades to come this surplus of
unproductive population living in cities
how to take refuge in slums shanty towns
and the informal economy but it was
already clear by the late 1960s that
neither development no modernization
understood as the outcome of a claw like
development ilysm
unfortunately sociology would be
possible anymore given Latin America's
imbalance between industrialization and
urbanization and I have also included an
image of one of the emblematic projects
of the para jimenez administration in
Venezuela in the 1950s the ventilator
the bendy tres de niro superblocks which
were already surrounded by the late
1960s bye-bye our shanty towns that of
course have developed much more since
then I'm going to work is now on
unchanged yourself of modernism as a
showcase within this context while
development ilysm are remain elusive in
economic and social terms some of Latin
America's metropolis is strive to
exhibit a modernist image that in view
of the imbalance between
industrialization and urbanization also
resulted in complete and distorted sorry
but it must be recognized that
architectural modernism was a showcase
for displaying the rapid modernization
pursued by economic development ilysm
whose nationalist ingredients color
vernacular and Janine modern isthmus in
some of Latin America's are developing
countries I'm not going to refer here to
sort of architectural examples which in
fact have been addressed to in previous
presentations I'm just passing to a sort
of the domain of planning in the domain
of urbanism major foreign influences in
post-war Latin America shifted from
academic season two functionalist our
modernism which serve like developmental
ISM and industrialization to the
progressive goals of democracies and
dictatorships likewise in consonance
with the third for a socialist
architecture since the administration of
alvaro obregon in Mexico in the early
1920s displayed in an ambitious program
of public hospitals and schools
sponsored by Minister jos Vasconcelos
and design for instance by guano Gorman
Jose villagran and one legarreta and I
think we have here one of our Goldman's
the school
our hi miss Myers left-wing rationalism
was introduced and bolster in Mexico
during the nineteen thirty-nine forty
nine stay of the former Bauhaus director
prior to that although it cannot be
considered an academic plan the plan
regulador of the federal district
coordinate coordinated by Carlos
Contreras pioneer of Mexico's urbanismo
Oh plan as young as it is also call was
closer to the tradition of thomas
adamson regional plan for New York
partly as a consequence of the fact that
the Mexican architect had studied in
columbia university and was trained in
New York in the New York plans of
regional office from 1919 are through
1925 and we can see here the proposed
plan coordinated by contrary by Carlos
Contreras the modern legacy in over
Latin American Capital was enraged
during the 1940s especially through the
visit of luminaries from there are
international congresses of modern
architecture some that advised the new
planning institutions some of which came
to be to have sorry national competence
I'm not going to refer here to the
episode of liquid VCS first visit ok to
Argentina and to the southern cone
because I was told to sort of reduce the
presentation but it's just an image that
that reminds that fundamental visit of
liquid was here in the late 1920s cm's
theoretical presence in Latin America
will be consolidated with your spanish
edition of the 1941 are charlatans
publish our lips publish enough armed
argentina in 1954 completed with ass
cuban adaptation in martinez inc lands
codigo de venise MO after visits to
havana of modernist maestro's such as
Richard Neutra Walter Gropius and Yosef
Elvis Sam's leadership among generations
of Cuban architects was took over by
host
we said advisor of the new Kunta
national de planificacin or national
board of planning created in 1955 by
Batista's dictatorship in the nineteen
fifty-seven master plan proposed by the
catalan urbanist jean-claude nickel as
per sts 1920s image of havana as a sort
of needs of the caribbean whose plan we
can see here to the left arm was
replaced by a proposal surrounded by the
means of las vegas or by ami aim at
creating a regional center for tourism
that included a complex of hotels a
business city in the style of the
Courvoisier MCM inspired grids of for
the working class residential suburbs
and we can see our self plans are to the
right to with some of the type blocks
that were proposed having arrived from
the late 1940s in Venezuela but
especially during / he menaces
dictatorship which took place in na in
the 1950s until nineteen fifty eight
planning was advocated by third himself
Robert Moses Frances village and Maurice
roti ball again all of them advisors of
the Commission national de venise no
national commission of planning the
french visitor I mean roti ball left
testimonies of the rise of the new
planning technique in the postwar years
what contrasted with his more academic
stands during his stay in the late 1930s
when he had coordinated the first urban
plan for Caracas and there is an image
of of the first plan are to the top to
the right which was a much more academic
as a sort of both art inspired plan and
I have forgot to mention that of course
we have here very feminist on going out
of one of the leader institutions of the
leading institution of the period the
Banco over a donor which was very much
advocated to Houston hired for the
second time by the Venezuelan government
wrote eval did not wish to be consider
any more any longer as field
easter was as a representative of the
more comprehensive professional that the
plan tificate herb was supposed to be
according to our differentiation that he
would theorize about some years later i
have some reference also in the
conference in the name text to the ole
each but i'm just to skip it for the
sake of of of the time in the case of
breast er sorry and there are also there
is also the image of the planner
regulador de caracas which was promoted
by the Committee on national do Rubin is
mo which was a sort of modernist plant
published in 1951 using sort of CM
concepts are like neighborhood unit etc
and to the right we have the image of a
neighborhood unit designed by stairs for
one of the oil camps in Venezuela
England Venezuela in the case of Brazil
after the introduction of international
modernism to South paulo by in 1923 by
the Russian Gregorovitch at chick cm
representatives on the curb UCS proposal
for real fuel the functional is momentum
that would reach his peak in cost us and
amaya Brazilians of course after the
attached sketches of via dokes service
serving us high-rise residences at the
same time which were produced during the
nineteen twenty-nine visit Lego Bashir
went back in 1936 to Brazil where some
of his proposals were more contextual
I'd including the building of the
minister ministry of health and
education and health which was referred
to yesterday in the presentation about
South Africa imbued with industrialism
and developmental ISM of those decades
another experience that confirms
Brazil's fascination with science
functionalism was a saddaji does
midori's or city of engines as 25,000
people settlement that will provide
services for an aeronautic factory
northwards of real the functional is
momentum
would reach its climax in the following
decade when the new capital city
promoted by president you Selena
kubacheck was completely undertaken by a
national team led by Lucio Costa an
Oscar Niemeyer it was finally evans that
the professional maturity of Brazilian
architecture and planning were able to
international eerie sound without the
presence of foreign maestro's having
worked with kubacheck when he was mayor
of belarus donkey niemeyer was
responsible for many of resilience
buildings laid out over Costas plan
whose aircraft like shape has been
interpreted not only as a reference to
the CM fetish and the rationality of the
Roman castrum but also as an allusion to
Brazil's take off and drive to
development by those years on the
transition from urban is notable any
jamendo in Brazil was a sped up by
father Joe celebrates visit to South
Paulo and all the Brazilian cities where
he advocated the principles and
variables of regional and economic
planning as a new technique to deal with
a sprawl of metropolitan areas the
awareness of new approaches to regional
planning in the professional media was
Evans in the criticism against the
Brazilian plan for not having
incorporated more economist ecologist
and social scientist as it was spelled
out by the anthropologist you were too
afraid a leading boys Brazil's Social
Sciences are Costas reply was not only
clever I think but also representative
of a turning point of the discipline the
new capital city was not supposed to be
Kosta said the outcome but the cost or
the origin of a regional plan okay and
I'm going to move to the last section we
have time don't we in which I will try
to sort of summarize this transition on
the urbanismo and planning to city and
and city and region it is not a
coincidence that the use of the term
Albanese mode during the first decades
of the 20th century in Latin America was
replaced after the Second World War by
planificacin or play miento in Spanish
and by planejamento import in Portuguese
there are some considerations that I
include here but is there are some
nuances which make that they are not
mirrored synonyms they have a sort of
technical connotation well although and
one can trace that a bit a historical in
you autocar dooner which we can see here
are to the left car owners famous manual
urbanismo published in bogota in
1939-1945 s eyes the region as a
territorial ambit it did recognize
regional planning as a new technique
whose antecedents dated back to
Schmidt's planning of the whole passing
and gazes Civic studies for Edinburgh
but contemporary breakthroughs according
to the Austrian urbanist had that word
in chile and colombia from the 1920s
until the late 1930s were mainly
illustrated by experiences of the
Regional Planning Association of America
in New York and in california regional
considerations had been incorporated of
course armed to the contextual studies
and theoretical frameworks of some of
the first local plans of latin american
capital from contra disease indella
paul-etta's plan for mexico city and
when Osiris respectively to a gadget a
gaseous and roti bars plan for real and
caracas and we can see Delabole de our
right to the top and his first proposal
of a regional plan for when Osiris our
laboratories created in the mid-1920s
sorry for no have included the captions
in order in all the cases I'm gonna ride
mainly from the USA are through all
those representatives will
European maestro's like wrote eval or
third and i think that in this morning's
presentation about cert was made a
comment about this perception of this
maestro's a sort of American oriented
monstrous in the local melius the
regional planning and Theon
functionalism continued amalgamating the
diverse methodological influences that
define the emerging planificacin
ranging from economic and social to
regional and systemic Orion's those main
streams will combine in different ways
in Latin America's planning institutions
which expanded from the local to the
national scale it seemed that in this
continent was being materialized the
institutionalization that Young had
experienced after the Second World War
which had made the movement turn from
leading the band word to representing
the establishment and I just want to
conclude that there are exceptions of
course and there are different
treatments of the term for instance
planning enjoy Mexico always had a
different I mean was used from the very
beginning but there was in the long term
a sort of unification of the term
planificacin with this new sort of
conception of modernity coming from the
USA after the second world war in the
heyday I just want to conclude by side
so it landed in the heyday of
development ilysm Latin America's
planificacin aren't planning amento
ended up not only being associated with
techniques and ambit drawn from regional
planning but also defined by its
relationship with political economic and
social aims and goals as it happened in
other parts of the world during the
1960's thank
well good afternoon firstly I would like
to thank the opportunity to be here with
all of you and to share common interests
and the presentation i'm bringing today
is part of an ongoing PhD research in
urbanism addressing the morphological
interpretation of the metropolitan
region of lisbon in portugal from an
infrastructural matrix it aims at
bringing forward the processes where and
by which infrastructure and territory
are combined at specifically
metropolitan morphologies so the focus
the core focus of my presentation or of
my research is not particularly theory
or history but i'm hoping to have some
useful contribution to the discussion so
firstly a short overview of the
presentation which is structured in
three points the first of which
addresses the date of 1940 a date with
specific interest because it congregates
various public works in lisbon which
have or which offer a metropolitan
vision secondly in 1967 is the date in
which the last comprehensive municipal
master plan for Lisbon is made before
the democratic revolution of 1974 and
finally a short discussion on the
territorial transformations in between
so in 1940 we have to firstly
acknowledge that Portugal was coming
through a dictatorship starting in
nineteen thirty three which lasted until
1974 which called itself the new state
the study law the political agenda
behind such regime claim during the
identity rebirth of the nation through
authoritarian practice and
solid state institutions infrastructure
development and modernization were key
to this agenda the architecture and
planning practice were instrumental in
forums for instance the public works as
expression of political initiative of
the regime and they were also areas
where design innovations could be
associated to these new infrastructural
apparatus in other cases it was being
difficult to introduce design
innovations for instance associated with
modernism but infrastructure was one of
the areas where such an expression could
be introduced urbanization was also
taken as a central role of the state
countering current practice until then
the first slide with some pictures which
illustrate this conservative and rather
patronizing agenda of study novo cam
form from a very peculiar drawings made
for elementary school manuals which
showed the lesson of Salazar and the
head of the political regime in the in
these pictures we show the claim for a
traditional architecture and domestic
family fem values associated with state
transformation transformation operated
by a style move it also expresses the
infrastructural modernization in the
lower pictures associated with its
political agenda now drafting more
tracing or cartographic the territorial
transformations occurring during this
the initial stages of HW move from 1902
1940 we see the first steps on
programming a city expansion to the
north so instead of having just highly
centralized an historical center these
during this period
number of initiatives are being drawn to
program the city expansion and to define
a pre metropolitan frame for which
public infrastructure public works are
vital so going beyond the city
boundaries the metropolitan scale can be
can be associated with a number of
public works for which I'm just showing
three of them let's see if I can show
them here the first of which is Monsanto
Forest Park a hill to the west of the
city which was enfora stood until then
the course to do so which is disclosed
to the west and a new highway which was
being programmed to develop this entire
region and the waterfront road going
through the Atlantic Ocean the first
world the first of these planning
initiatives the course the boussole
master plan was mainly based on a dual
interest on a dual approach to
infrastructure first a very definitive
structure accompanying the coastline
with two axes which rendered a frame for
metropolitan expansion and then the
second highly detailed zoning master
plans for local areas around and in
between of these infrastructures the way
how this highway was introduced into the
city is particularly evident of how
architecture and infrastructure are
combined for instance the very
functional and structural elements of
this bridge reaching the city and then a
more monumental celebration of
public space with a highly detailed and
monumental area for sightseeing and
Belvedere Inc nowadays it isn't used
like this and this area was never built
nevertheless the road was becoming a key
landscape and architectural concern for
instance in the marginal in strategy now
the waterfront roadway which I have
shown we shown you in the previous slide
we can see an entanglement of landscape
with infrastructure defining a new
perceptual and cultural references for
the city life the detail and
architectural quality of such design is
also a remark of how these work roads
were designed they were programmed by
the National Board of roads one of the
state central institutions drafted by
the new state which for the first time
incorporated architects with the
specific aim of improving the landscape
quality of Road design so a new
landscape started to be perceived and
assimilated mostly by the car the car
was a key important factor in this in
this perception so belvedere's the
scenic pathways and even more detailed
traffic signature was part of this new
landscape the landscape work which was
starting to become infrastructural this
is also the time during which new
planning paradigms are being integrated
into Portuguese urban planning in here
we have the municipal master plan of
Lisbon which was being elaborating from
nineteen thirty eight to nineteen forty
eight in which you can see the
importance of landscape in combination
we need infrastructure for instance the
parkways which defines owning sectors
and parkways was a specific term used by
the architect Etienne de Kock the coil
francha garion architect which studied
in Paris he draws the term parkways into
the memoir of the master plan so it's a
rather eclectic formation behind this
approach also abound in greenbelt was to
be built around the city for which the
monsanto park was one of the key
instrument of this green belt it is also
interesting to see one diagram of taken
from etienne de corps in a memoir he has
made in which he defines a theoretical
model for a city with satellite cities
it's very close resemblance with Howard
on diagram these new paradigms of urban
and metropolitan development and it's
planning can also be associated with the
distribution the regional distribution
of activities for instance the leisure
and sports facilities associated also
with nationalist celebrations like for
instance the national stadium to the
west of Monsanto all of these works as I
was saying before had in some degree the
involvement of architects working also
in Central Public Works authorities this
involvement allowed for architects to
play an active role in the diversity in
scale and scope of intervention it was
also the background from which it was
possible to introduce some design
innovations namely of some modern
references in this case these three
pictures show three works then by
architect Paul leukemia which was
working in the Port Authority of Lisbon
where we can see that he was able to
define two
valid special layouts and more detail
architected architectonic features
designed for port areas in which modern
references are clearly introduced in
another set outside of these
infrastructural works we can see that
the designed comprehensive urban
planning and design is facing a more
slow transition from formal urban
expansion greeted sectors to a modern
development or based on housing
neighborhoods this case is the
neighborhood of other lads where we can
see the definition of agreed
establishing housing neighborhoods but
still accommodating for a rather formal
urban design however it is also possible
to detect the different type ologies and
design innovations which are being
introduced in transition between 1949
later on 1967 so going to 1967 it's
important to address the context which
is mainly based on the changing role of
the state which no longer will be the
sole provider of infrastructure and
housing development but it will focus
singly in infrastructure relinquishing
the extensive expropriation powers that
it had gained in the previous period and
the housing development to private
sector it also focuses on an economic
policy based on industrial sectors the
building industry the chemical industry
are associated with the most important
Planning development
this cartography shows the
intensification of suburbanization
during the period from 1942 1967 it also
shows the unequal earlier urban
development occurring inside the city
the municipal boundary which is here
inside of which there is a substantial
work than by architects municipal
architects young fresh fresh minded
architects which can accommodate for the
introduction of new references and also
they can work in previously expropriated
land so the implementation is not
difficult however outside of these areas
along the suburbanization access that
quality that are spatial and
architectonic quality is much poorer
infrastructure provision is also much /
outside of Lisbon so infrastructure one
can say that is starting to get behind
of the Metropolitan Development now one
of these these pictures show the two
neighborhoods developed in the northern
part of Lisbon which show exactly this
transition to a modern reference
although seasoned with North European
references which have a very qualified
public light housing development and
we're open space becomes the ground or
freestanding building so this is the
starting point of the disruption between
infrastructure and ervin design this
disruption can also be seen in the
municipal master plan of 1967 where we
can see it rise but sectoral LED urban
planning high-capacity transportation
becomes the planning backbone as we can
see in the middle picture namely by the
introduction of a new bridge to the
south bank of the river zoning
segregation and morphological disruption
a company
transition which can be seen in the
areas which I was mentioning earlier the
areas be outside of the municipal
boundary or in its limits such as
benfica which has a plan which is
partially executed but which is much
more based on one a less elaborate urban
design based on infrastructure all only
and no longer the buildings this other
plan which was not implemented shows
also this kind of morphological
disruption and like the previous one the
one to the left we can see a number of
buildings expressively designed but with
very little expression on the
infrastructure support behind it in fact
this large open rectangle here would be
a new central train station for the city
it was never built but look how the plan
almost ignores the presence of this
planned railway station and so this
starts to be the background for urban or
metropolitan development the disruption
is no longer the disruption comes also
from the inability of planning to curb
with housing demand the rise of a lazy a
fair approach to private development
which produce produces disrupted
landscape in which infrastructure and
housing are no longer accommodated into
a comprehensive planning this is also
the time during which the first regional
plan is drawn 1964 so this is the first
metropolitan plan for the entire region
it is focused mainly on infrastructure
settlements the settlement patterns and
the emphasis on landscape and
t'kul areas its main strategies were of
urban containment and functional d
concentration namely of industrial areas
to the south bank and we can say that it
became the first truly metropolitan plan
because it also incorporated a number of
ring roads working as d concentration
corridors to the rest of the
metropolitan area some of these
infrastructures took almost 40 years to
build this time gap is in fact a quite
important data so a short discussion on
the territorial transformations we can
see from these two time periods in 1914
we witness a pre metropolitan planning
with great former detail at local scales
and the more schematic approach at
larger ones the role of the architect
was of building a spatial and cultural
identities through design and
specifically with Public Works in 1967
we witness a change of this role and of
this condition with the collapse of
recalling what Graham and Marvin have
called the modern infrastructural ideal
the time and the financial gap between
planning and implementation becomes a
very important topic to address because
it's no longer the state with its
ability to have holding the
infrastructural and the housing and the
industrial provision working together at
the same time and so inequalities from
center to peripheral areas are starting
to increase the role of the architecture
during this in the 60s is also changing
it becomes more sectoral minded
disciplinary separated from
infrastructure and so we witness a
design point
during of infrastructure and the
architectonic object just to trace and
to bring such points within the
metropolitan development since then we
can see that from 1967 to 1992 we have
seen extensive urban growth xscape inc
formal planning especially in these
areas and great difficulties in
infrastructural development much of the
urban in initiatives drawn in the 1964
metropolitan plan was not built in this
period 1992 or not still built they were
built later on in the late 20th century
in which we can see finally more mature
stabilization of infrastructural of
infrastructure bringing a more
polycentric region a redevelopment
around ring roads and but also a
continuing difficulty in closing the gap
between public planning and private
development the next step in this in
this development will probably bring a
new scale of operation to the metropolis
with the introduction of high-speed
train connecting to Madrid a new bridge
and a new international airport so the
final slide just work on concluding
remarks I would say that infrastructural
landscapes are a field of overarching
perceptual and cultural implications
which demand a research into the
pioneering metropolitan approaches in
the 40s and ultimately I think we need
to elaborate on the disruption between
the project of infrastructure and the
project of the city thank
thank you for liking
I begin my account of this architecture
making of the State of Israel with this
somewhat elusive image of the National
Museum of Israel designed in 1959 and
open to the public in 1964 I will try
today an impossible rhetorical loop in
order to embed the iconography of the
museum within a larger territorial
construct or rather to read the
formative master plan of Israel through
the special scheme of the museum this is
the museum is a museum and more lessons
opening in the mid-60s I will not refer
to the beautiful round capture the right
this is keesler is a shrine of the book
and not also will also not refer to the
beautiful garden by design by noguchi
only to the cubicle structure on the
left this museum was conceived as a
national art and archaeology museum it
was programmed to be both the stockroom
of tangible historical evidence and the
showcase of a rejuvenating nation the
sign of its creative force in 1959 an
architectural competition was set up to
determine the museum's architect the
winning project by architects Alfred
mansfeld and or God childhood in tears
was the least presumptuous proposition
it was reductive rigorous and at the
same time picturesque the board's
submitted to the competition by the
architects left no room for
misinterpretation regarding their
pictorial inspiration at the top of the
first board appeared in an illogical
sketch depicting in our village
specified in writing is the village of
Malka near jerusalem and below it
drawing freehand as a mirror image a
perspective and plan of the proposed
museum
as we learn from the competition
proceedings it was this sketch
disenchanting homology that caught the
attention of the jury and was the prime
reason for the choice of this project
the Arab village of Makkah was thus
consecrated as the myth of origin
authenticating the national museum to be
it should be explained that the lands of
Makkah a village emptied of its
inhabitants during the war of 1948 were
confiscated by the Israeli authorities
and suspended under the legal definition
of deserted property it's masonry houses
were spared and used as temporary
accommodations for new Jewish immigrants
usually of North African origins later
on during the 60s the immigrants were
engineered into prefab housing projects
while malca went through a process of
gentrification it was now colonized by
resourceful squatters Bohemians of all
sorts could appreciate its beauty and
converted sliggoo status in order to buy
the houses and established an artists
colony that would cancel out any
possible quest for return by the
original owners this image describes
such a situation in a nearby village and
carry a New Jerusalem we see here a new
Jewish immigrants entering a deserted
Road and destroyed our houses
against such actual process of
expropriation it is hardly surprising to
find the ghostly image of Malka emerging
in architectural drawings as their
poetic truth factor for most of these
really cultural community the Arab
village did not represent antagonistic
reality of political conflict it was the
sign of the sensuous native the soft
image of organic anti monumental
spontaneous architecture in fact many
local artists and architects of the time
were obsessed with Arab or Mediterranean
imagery but these in a museum maybe the
first and the most celebrated instance
of its embodiment in actual built form a
village for a village a photo collage
created by village sandberg the Israeli
museum's first director describes the
new museum and the vernacular village
flattened into one seamless and painless
continuum Sandberg's pre Photoshop
graphics is devoid of any reflexive
dimension it is not an acerbic critique
about the technique of montage nor about
the orientalist gaze of the architect
but rather a trivial fascination with
the effects of architecture masquerade
that allows the blurring of historical
narrative into timelessness and the
subversion of war of brutality into
hysterical synchronicity by the way
strangely enough this image was sold as
a posterior the museum store for many
many years was a very popular a poster a
look at the museum's elevation reveals
that alongside the appealing contour of
the Arab village the museum is haunted
with yet another image that of Miss
found the rose and built house of night
unbuilt brick house of 1923 but a brief
study of the museum's plans reveals that
Miss is indeed misappropriated by
mansfeld emission decomposed volumes are
valued for the pictorial effect the
freestanding walls and floating plains
becoming mosfets plan modular boxes
situated arbitrarily electrographic
matrix indeed the systemic layout and
pattern language of vision museum is
above all a local dialect of 1950s
structuralist architecture
it was mentioned or discussed before in
other presentations mas felt like many
Israeli architects of the late 50s and
60s was directly influenced in front
back in ten was deeply engaged in the
articulation of a new kind of binary
thinking which organized base elements
into spatial patterns henceforth
referred to as clusters habitats
beehives carpets mega forms and other
rhetorical crossings between the
mechanical and organic these are other
models still models by man spelled who
shows how these structures could grow
horizontally and vertically what is so
new and convenient about this
terminology it's beside the fact that is
not architecture I the traditional sense
of form giving or space making it
rejects the predetermined object and the
stable form in favor of an epigenetic
system a system that reproduces /
mutates and abducts itself through time
and space the actual built result and I
believe that Israel Museum is one of the
finest existing built examples anywhere
is an aggregation of modular cells with
no definite shape or finite contour we
see still marvel the same architect with
a completely different scale of thinking
now it's in it's an urban scale in fact
the most useful quality of structuralist
architecture is its elasticity and
expensively expandability on prescribed
matrix and according to a predetermined
code without changing its genetic code
in the case of Israel Museum for example
it grew in size in an area ten times
since its inception ten times I don't
know if there is any precedent for such
a building without changing its its
character or even its appearance
these are still original sketches from
the competition from the original
competition in 1959 so behind the soft
weak image of nebulous fragmentation
lurks ideological expansionism as the
second nature of structurally
architecture the abandonment of the
proper object of the autonomous figure
of the building opens up the practice of
incremental incremental growth and
elusive crawl such slow motion always
appears is more sustainable and moderate
because never in tears massive
demolition radical change of scale or
monumental impositions it devolves
through the dissemination of small-scale
units naturalized as it were in the
geography camouflages local folklore but
then it spreads like cancer covers
ground in most efficient way it has the
indigenous paradigm into a displacement
machine masters title of his own work
growth change and uncertainty summarizes
the logic of structuralist architecture
at large but it also provides an astute
insight into the principal drive and the
guiding politics or logistics of its
really architecture after the war of
1967 growth change in sure enough
uncertainty is a modus operandi operandi
and surfing dodging board and I'm
disorder in this paper however I will
not further discuss this post 67
tendency it is what started in
elaborated in the work of white wine
cigarettes civilian occupation instead
in the context of our conference I will
return to the formative years of Israeli
statehood and their architectural scene
foraging I will try to argue first that
Israel is a construct an architectural
fabrication an instant master plan a
brief design that was executed verbatim
and second that the picturesque village
mentality of the National Museum is not
at all eccentric but indeed highly
consistent and legible against the
background of Zionist rule provincial
and electronic ideology
according to this argument then the
collection of the National Museum and
the planning of Israel are different
scales of a common quest for urgent
authenticity for emblematic Organa city
for instance vernacular for makeshift
regionalism for modular and modulated
formlessness it's quite different maybe
the results finally would be very
similar those in Portugal in other
places but the motivation it is my
argument a completely different all in
all if Zionism is the case of particular
interest it is because it practices
architecture to the extreme it
compensates for historical deficiency by
hyper planning it denies stable form by
maintaining an open-ended process of
morphing it draws maps of masquerade of
an over again to measure the
vulnerability and negotiability of
boundaries so let us now look at the
national scale contrary to common belief
contrary to common belief and to visual
impression Israel was not born of
hazzard improvisation emergency
emergency solutions or speculative
entrepreneurship but rather of the
unprecedented objective to put into
practice one of the most comprehensive
controlled and efficient architectural
experiments in the modern era in this
indeed this maybe is worth singularity
among nations or states or nation states
it was systematically worked out in
advance by planning professionals of
various disciplines in order to carry
out ben gurion's prescript to transform
the country the nation our entire modes
of life nagoya of course was the first
leader or the founder of the state first
prime minister we see him here in the
center the short man and you can guess
that the taller man behind it with the
camera of course is the architect and
i'm not going to talk about pressure on
presidents and direct references to the
Israeli project can be found in Stalin's
five-year plan for the Soviet Union in
the American New Deal infrastructural
projects of the 30s in the German
national socialist regional plans for
the occupied territories of Poland and
in the post-war British New Towns I'm
just referring to those who were direct
influences on Israeli planners but it's
sweeping vision exceeding all
instrumental models and circumstantial
explanations is rooted in the utopian
imagination and redemptive praxis of the
Zionist movement his roots kovacevich
elaboration so as to reenact the bedding
upon which the master plan of Israel was
drafted immediately upon the outbreak of
the state the very notion of how phallic
seoni were the Zionist enterprise and
forged a highly institutionalized
explicitly synthetic and actively
constructive nature of the process of
land appropriation and nation-building
where the Jews in the 20th century we
see her this image is from the Halal one
of the first semi collective settlements
designed by the assad government any
attempt to normalize Zionism by
overemphasizing aspects such as
spontaneous immigration organic
settlement or market forces misses the
point the artificial essence of Zionism
the grounding of its rhetoric and
lotions on such notions as negation
inversion or synthesis it's served the
finishing as a constraint corrective
redemptive when we don't even use the
term messianic intervention in
historical time and geographical space
in this context centralized planning is
the ultimate rope that binds words and
things this design dispute it self
immolating emanating from layers of
fictional prose ideological manifestos
or programmatic protocols and printing
printed on the landscape over and over
again to every new special move or
architectural object
this is already this is another type of
rural settlement this is a key boots we
don't have time here to really explain
what it is but this is really the
referring to a previous presentation
here there are no private kitchens at
all okay there's a private property and
this is the the most radical this is
devin guard pioneering settlement the
most conspicuous use of centralized
planning not merely for territorial
organization but rather as an apparatus
molding in erie thurs is manifested in
the consistent efforts to shift the
political cultural and economic wake
from the city to the countryside and
from the center to the periphery as a
rule it may be said that in its fifty
years roughly the first half of the 20th
century the its first 50 years the
Zionist movement device and developed a
range of pioneering models of Abdul
cultural settlements but never imagined
plant or actually built a city in fact
the modern metropolitan city was
consistently portrayed in both literary
utopia's and direct propaganda as an
impediment to the Zionist concept of
language redemption a parasitic growth
threatening to undermine the fundamental
values of the re-emerging Hebrew
civilization what you see here is an
image is a poster from an exhibition
from a misty propaganda exhibition
showed that the television museum
already 9050 by the by the planet can
see by the government by the state in
order to convince people to move from
the center to the periphery this is one
board we'll see a few more from this
exhibition that's revolutionary
objectives totally controlled planning
and an a well coordinated coast faction
had characterized the Zionist Enterprise
from its very outset however the
country's crucial conversion was
obtained with the founding with was
obtained only with the founding of the
sovereign state of israel and the end of
the richmond
in 1948 only a few weeks after the
declaration of independence are you sure
lon not to be confused with yellow
chevron if I was graduate and also the
newest student finest Meyer who was
mentioned before and was worked for
hannah's meyer and i think that you also
joined the trip to Moscow that was
mentioned before so I this is Arya
sharone from the bios who was also one
of the prominent architects of his labor
movement was commissioned to establish
the governmental planning department
because immediately in fact it was
already during the the end of the war
the pressing national task assigned to
sharon and his team by of planners was
providing temporary housing solutions
for the masses of new jewish immigrants
and settle and settling the country's
border lands in order to stabilize the
1940s fire lines prevent territorial
concessions and inhibit the return of
palestinian war refugees what we see
here is really a temporary camps this by
the way were designed by architects who
are even designed by Luke on another
Jewish American architects for the same
for these camps believe it or not the
panel accomplished this by drafting
statewide network of civil frontiers
composed of transit camps as we see here
and i'll post agrarian settlements as
well as by recycling deserted our
villages with new jewish immigrants here
we see new jewish immigrants in Jaffa
and this is another example of an Arab
village we see already this process of
transformation taking place immediately
after the war these are difficult images
but this is the story to be to be told
concurrently a long-term mission was
outlined for the for the planning
department preparing a national master
plan
the first draft of this plan known
hereafter as the Sharon pen was
presented in 1950 its objectives were
targeted at a local population of
slightly over two and a half million
inhabitants which would be dispersed
throughout the country this is an image
from sharon's the autobiography which is
called kibbutz blues Bauhaus and this is
the chapter and describe describing the
the planning of the new land and ridges
in New Towns while it had no formally
approved legal status the Sharon plan
instantly within less than a decade
transformed from a principles document
to an enormous building project
embracing dozens of towns and hundreds
of rural settlements landscapes of
national parks nature resorts and
extensive woodlands networks of roads
ports and factories all entirely new all
designed XD hello according to
progressive theories and technologies of
the time in order to fabricate
synchronize and monitor irrational and
efficient mechanism for organic
regionalist and quasi historical
settlement in order to prevent it all
costs the development of unruly
settlement patterns typical of new world
countries or immigration countries the
Sharon plan chose to emulate the
European story clay out where but we're
by the majority of the population dwells
in small and medium-sized towns
integrated into their new cultural int'l
ined and only the minority lives in the
big cities what you see here is again
one of the posters the big threat is
less affair okay in Israel because if
there will be a less FF policy what we
see here is that eighty percent of the
new immigrants will live along the
shoreline in the in the big cities the
whole idea is to move from A to B this
is the idea of the plan to disperse the
population
across the country needless to say that
the origins of this Iraq hierarchic web
lie in the pre industrial culture and
reflect centuries of moderate organic
growth the planets of Israel tried to
squeeze this process into a single here
Ike decade backing their ambitions with
intricate sweeto scientific theories
that analyzed the link between
settlement patterns and induced during
times of crisis especially authoritative
for them was the theory of central
places formulated by GM and geographer
Valtor kiss Tyler in his 1939 doctoral
research I cannot elaborate on this very
painful issue you know that costata plan
was Lisbon axis for the occupied
territories of Poland ten years after it
was used consciously or or not by the
Israeli planet the basic tool suggested
by the plan for achieving the desirable
European layout was the reader vision of
the country into 24 districts no way
determined according to Geographic
characteristics and plan as arrays of
Kabukicho settlements clustered around
central villages and served by original
town over 400 agrarian settlements were
founded according to the plans
guidelines more or less the same number
of destroyed our villages 400 but its
epitome was the new district town
designed is an intimate town of 20,000
to 50,000 residents and assumed to be
exempt of the disorientation alienation
crime and speculative real estate is
associated with the cosmopolitan city
I'm just showing it quickly the plans of
these new towns in this valley lab in
new urban paradigm was created based on
the unlikely marriage of suburban garden
city in a western welfare state and a
peripheral industrial town in the
outskirts of devotion we can fire the
seemingly paradoxical Zionist attitude
of activating a regressive revolution or
a pioneering old world
may be discerned not only in the rural
dispersal of towns and settlements on
the map but also in the attempt to base
the architecture of the town's
themselves on a conceptual crossbreeding
between the mechanistic planning methods
striving to render the traditional city
more efficient in terms of mass housing
and motor vehicle traffic on one hand
and a pastoral pastoral or biomorphic on
sections on the other will to tone down
the city by fragmenting it into small
autonomous communities protected from
sweet life zoned off from industrial
sectors and rocked by green surroundings
this smooth flexing lines of the
neighboring units the abundance of open
space within and between them the
placement of education and recreation
facilities at the heart of the units
amidst lawns and woods the distancing of
industrial areas from living quarters
and the separation by green birds the
design of repetitive social housing on
undivided land nope oscillation rather
than normative hustling in speculative
construction all these lead us to the
conclusion that the new Israeli town was
meant to be a blown-up kibbutz based on
homogenous community collective and
egalitarian without private capital or
unanticipated market forces this is an
aerial view of a kibbutz however
unlikely kibbutz which was created as
exclusive hegemonic structure by and for
the members of a social avant-garde the
new town came into being superficially
and cohesively a political and strategic
doctrine forced upon a population of
unsuspecting newcomers use this passive
subject of a national experiment with
the foundation of the first new towns it
became apparent that the progressive
zoning principles and the generous
ecological attitude simply do not work
the detached sparsely populated rarely
make our way down disproportionately on
the national budget due to the huge
amount of infrastructure they demanded
one one minute okay come to the close
sixty years after its official
publication the Sharon plan still holds
its own
the vision of colonization and
modernization laid out by the plan has
for the most part being implemented this
world has developed at an unprecedented
rate of growth the new town still exists
more or less as they had originally been
planned bahrein Garden City's lethargic
work towns bypassed regional centers
homogeneous melting pots underdeveloped
or urban odds and ends in conclusion we
may observe that the intricacy of
Israel's internal and external
boundaries of today is already inscribed
at the scene of origin state by the
founders of Zionism the vision of return
to geography and to history outline in
Arcadian utopia a garden state instantly
naturalized that makes biblical
landscapes and constantly suspended in a
mode of change growth and instability
the image of organist II elasticity and
porosity obtain sorry embalmed in the
master plans of dozens of new towns and
hundreds of new rural settlements
authenticated as it were the texture of
homeland and illustrated figuratively
they taking place of place lacking I now
return to the National Museum or our
initial image of Perpetual change of
designed formas nests of course the
displacement and continual dialectics of
grounding and ungrounding this is how it
looks today I mean if you this picture
was taken a few days ago still a
building project still indulging in
negotiating its boundaries thank
time for discussion
so thank you all three of you for very
compelling papers covering a sort of
wide array of issues that have been on
the table a weekend I want to we don't
have a lot of time for discussion as
we're sort of crunching in towards the
end I wanted to serve ask one question
to the three of you and I just want to
then framing this give you an
opportunity to sort of expand on some of
the issues that I saw both in reading
and hearing at presentations now in
terms of how again we see the sort of
properties and characteristics in this
time period you know more or less of
surrounding to is the conference's
located the characteristics of
governance that emerges or become
transformed from the state into a
variety of non stage or sort of Kwazii
state practices right in each case of
courses is inflected somewhat
differently those practices of course
including architecture planning and sort
of territorial organization large how
that is accompanied by or is examined
through or can be can be discussed on
the terms of transformations of the sort
of technical purview of architecture I
saw in all of your papers are sort of
from two component right sort of from
the vanguard to the seats of power from
the sort of ornaments to sectional
planning and then from showcase to
masquerade
these transformations and what they can
say I'm starting with the architect and
sort of resonating I was afraid I have
to well yes I I think that in Latin
America I'm going to refer to the region
generally long yes i think that the
post-war period t is is is very
interesting in the sense that the state
the national state are assumes assume a
sort of corporate rule okay ah this
discord bread roll it will involve i
mean sort of taking on things that of
course were presents in the nineteenth
centuries in the beginning of the
earlier republican era but but were
taking on a new aspects of economic
production and of course the main
activity was interested i section okay
so perhaps i didn't emphasize that in my
presentation but we had a first wave of
essay is I or industrialization by
subsidy import substitution which came
from the before the war okay in
countries like Argentina and perhaps a
bit in Brazil and in Mexico but there
was a second wave ah by countries like
Peru and Venezuela and Colombia which
were after after Second World War and it
was a period in which are the state sort
of created on corporations are for him
sort of bolstering production we have
rings since the creation of an example
of chili with a cord fall in 1935 which
was fundamental for there for there for
industrial development until the 1970s
for instance but apart from the I mean
you're most referring to the topics of
of territory and space the main point
that I see after the
the Second World War was that the urban
issue that was already present in the
agenda in the public agenda by the
mid-1920s okay again in cities like when
Osiris and Mexico and major Brazilian
cities that that issue became a a
national one I mean the urban Asia
within a sort of national framework and
this is why these discs emissions like
the ones have referred to the the
national commission of Commissioners
Donald urbanismo in Venezuela or the
Hotel de planificacin in Cuba where
we're no longer local elements but they
had the inscription to that to the state
with a rank of a ministry for instance
okay or a regional cooperation so you
know I think this this sort of
assumption of the of the territorial
agenda the regional agenda within the
corporate state are we just so extended
the coordinates that I thought I try to
describe Willie will lead to by the
1960s and 70s to the sort of armed
evolution towards our estate that is
more a planner I mean a planning state
which is a different face I think and
that was very much influenced but by the
Soviet model which in many Latin
American countries came through France
to prove Frances influence so this is
you know gross model
well as to the governance practice I
would say that the first we can trace to
really two periods in Staten of pre-1940
or 1945 the end of the war portugal in
participate in the world but was
obviously affected by it and the
post-1945 and up until then and 1945 the
main issue was how to build the state
this new state and its institutional
apparatus and i believe that there is in
this process there is a key person which
didn't have the time to go into in the
presentation but in the paper it's there
which is the Minister of Public Works
from the nineteen 1940s at what a ship
it was an engineer a very committed man
with modernization with some cultural
references to the Future ISM and it was
really a very personalized way of
dealing with Urban Development
infrastructural development and this man
the Ministry of Public Works establishes
a national wide perspective on these
issues establishing very strong
legislation for Urban development's
giving extensive expropriation powers to
the municipalities for instance and so
it offers and also it provides a
fans to employ and employed people
directly in public works construction so
there is a combination of policies
targeted it's very specifically very
specifically at infrastructural
development but also with an economical
perspective from 1945 on in fact this
Minister he dies very young in 1942 and
the economical transformations of the
country are much more directed at an
industrial based development the
relationships with Europe require that
and the metropolitan approach really is
no longer based on a single entity
providing all the infrastructure and all
the other elements like housing but
focusing more sectoral early on specific
areas transportation for instance if
there is an agency a national agency for
transportation planning becomes almost a
minister on its own so the relationship
that there was with architects were
almost chosen personally by the minister
in the previous period so there was a
very strong combination between these
two levels it starts to operate in a
very stratified and splintered state in
state cartography like let's say and
this needs to provide industrial
background for development is no longer
aimed at specific special arrangements
on cities towns even rural improvements
which were very fostered during the
1940s but are working on a more regional
approach so this scale disruption and
morphological disruption has to do with
that governance disruption also the
Israeli design is Israeli cases is quite
particular and uncomplicated innocence
but what is really really it's not
really certainly not first of all it's
not third world it's not also second
world it's not totalitarian regime sort
of offer quite progressive ins on
perception but yet here is a comes up
with the most ambitious totalizing
project that could imagine anything that
you is in precedent for such a such a
total mass great architecture project
and and there is almost nothing outside
this project nothing beyond this project
for for a decade 450 is the work for two
decades fifties and sixties and it's
difficult to explain because you know
this supposedly free market economy
architects of free people you know the
great architects of a conscious modern
architecture contemporary theories and
clothes and so on but still there is
nothing but state apparatus state
architecture and this one big project
everything should to conform with this
this project and this almost no
opposition no other ways to do it to go
about it moreover it's it's certain so
most is kind of a survivalist instinct
that almost every planning after it
architecture in this period in israel
has to do with a certain territorial
consciousness or territorial in 10 I'm
saying territory of course meaning is
political could also say strategical
military but it's a i would say milti
because it's always civil settle
civil occupation in fact what we see
today the settlements you know beyond
so-called green line in the West Bank
and Gaza is just a continuation of a
practice that's what I was trying to
describe goes on like that for from from
the beginning from the outset of the
Zionist settlement in Palestine Israel
so this is why you every every text back
is first of all and above all a
territorial or spatial process
placemaking and it's always about this
process and therefore it's always in
determine indeterminate in the sense
that it will it will always avoid the
object the form the boundaries Israel to
this day doesn't have a a contour you
know if you are scared there's an
Israeli kid to draw a map you know every
normal kid in every others taking a look
do it is very key do not know how to do
it because still undecided still
negotiable so this is one issue the
other issue of course is the commission
of masquerade of the modern
architectural modernism has masquerade
and again it's we don't have time to
fully discuss it but you know Israel in
the 30s 20s and 30s or 40s and 50s 60s
as well it's a case of really extreme
modernism tentative is a city of the
Bauhaus it is so cold and and fifties
architecture in Israel it's it's highly
and a modernist more than perhaps other
places you will not find any
neoclassicism you know regression so to
speak you know so hard work have
contemporaneous with what's going on
Europe but then it's always Mullen isn't
without modernization there was no
industrial evolution Israel was now
technical
modernity there were no big cities again
as i described Zionism anti urban
movement it's very it's very critical of
majority but so i think that the
modernism the look that pains the water
pills this is propagated by the zionist
movement in a very specific way i used
to write about it like other people as a
sign of a young nation you know and so
on but i think that today I think of it
is something that is much more
complicated this is what I was trying
for the first time to bring up a
newspaper its relationship with the
local will make you the indigenous and
the dire need which is above everything
else to to authenticate itself instant
instantaneously to root it off to create
this kind of quasi historical presence
via mother is a language i just asked at
something because I notice that perhaps
I emphasize too much the point of the
corporate state as a as a producer I'll
put it it's also they give them back
going back to the territorial agenda are
that yes I mean this this corporate
state is also very much working on the
processing of regionalization of the
country and this is start after the
world war two and goes i would say until
the 1970s and again this browse this
process of of regionalization arm adopts
in some cases the the model of the
corporation in fact as I think it
happened in some cases within new towns
in Britain as far as I understand i mean
in order to sort of speed up the process
of urbanization of new towns in in some
regions the model of the corporation was
much more effective than going up
working only with the central
administration so the the corporate our
state also has this sort of territorial
front that that is working very hard and
it will be in some cases
um back in the 1960s I would say and 70s
with a legal parameters of
regionalization I mean they they create
the official creation of regions by
decrees usually and got given to those
corporate original corporation sort of
legal status without within the central
administration it's very compelling how
these questions of sort of modernity
modernism modernization
draw attention to or brilliant focus the
very term region it seems that we've
been using it little casually that there
is a shift in the idea of region from
you no state to non-state names and it's
I mean it's something that gives meaning
to the farm term that emerges in the
post Florida to give meaning to
different processes of change the idea
of regions probably question is to throw
an draw that the idea of region
professed in rust all stages model is
that there are series of fixed ages and
you measure the transformation according
to this criteria and whatever doesn't
fit that model is seen as a disruption
but when we move to emergence of
non-state actors what was previously
seen as destructions become precisely
the forces are considered precisely the
forces of which are driving change so
how does the idea of region then changes
from something which is you know a
series of layers or see the stage is
imposed on each other to something which
can give meaning to these all these
forces which were previously seen as
disruptive but now seen as productive
just to give I guess one example I would
have used the example of the
transformation from cadiz to Smith sins
very section actually there is a
difference it's not a simple replication
I wish we had the slide gaddy's is it
shows one mountainside you know the the
settlements are just coming down and
it's seen as an evolutionary diagram
Smithson's replicated and their two
sides so is seen as something which can
be replicated seven it becomes a pattern
and which I think one cannot you gives a
very different idea of region is
something a continuous transforming
dynamic so I wonder in your examples how
would you characterize the
transformation in the conception of
region
okay so in the case of Lisbon we don't
have regions and we didn't have regions
in 1967 or in 1940 which is an
interesting debate we have two levels of
government the national level and the
municipal level and this tension is
really something to be a little bit
explored like I said the in 1964 we had
the first regional plan it was called
like that plane delayed or delusion
which were really the directive plan for
the region of Lisbon they call it
breached reaching nowadays we call it a
metropolitan area institutionalized by
decree but with really very little
powers so there is no metropolitan level
or regional level of power but you are
making a distinction between how this
regional approach could be into seen as
a corrective for a more proactive form
of development of planning for instance
i would say that in the case of lisbon
this first plan 1964 plan was more of
work both on both ends both as of as a
corrective instrument to accommodate for
a very fast growing expansion of the
city but without the proper
infrastructure to service all of the
area and on the other side it worked as
part of a national policy of progressive
planning there was the
the National meant to plans Latin I
don't know the translation into English
that almost almost like the Soviet
five-year planning but in this case
associated with the right-wing regime in
which these regional areas played a very
volunteer istic approach to
industrialization so the region was
interfacing element in between this
national government and local
governments but without having really an
institutional level of authority so it
was always something in between the
central authority and its abilities were
in abilities to control development and
the local level which was very fable
which was very weak municipal power was
very weak and it was met all much about
private development and its ability to
go into specific doors in the national
governments of the region is a much of
an abstraction on the first at the first
side and also a new bureaucratic term or
concept yes i think that the perhaps it
developed in the developmental is
melissa rajee's one in its first moment
arm perhaps did not work immediately
with it with a with the apparatus of the
region I think um perhaps this is very
general not it could be differences
obviously in between the countries but
what what it did our sort of sport the
sort of national administration we're
working with the development of these
models was a necessity of of vacuums on
some regions because of the territorial
imbalances and they create for instance
of New
towns and in that respect the sort of
the idea of regional development was
very long very much associated from the
beginning to the desert ridge easement
okay in the in the first moment I'm
talking about and I would say for
instance the the development of eros
cylia could be I don't know whether my
Brazilian colleagues here could correct
me but for instance the creation of Nova
cap which was a corporation which
supported the development and they and
they and the construction of Brasilia
was was the result of that another
example with these pseudo vagina in in
south of a southeast of Venezuela
because I mean by the 1950s the National
Board of planning that I refer to
decided so to speak that it was
necessary to UM to sort of reinforce the
development of the Southwest by South
East by creating a new city which sort
of sort of counterpart the the north
coast development of a nice fella urban
development okay so this is why are the
two that was on a plan i don't know
whether you are familiar with that plan
but it was sort of developed by the late
1950s and 2000 60s in fact with a
supportive of legal teamed from MIT and
you know sort of very specialized team
but i think that there is a second stage
i would say and this is a very general
periodization in which are the sort of
notion of region are it supported by the
institutional apparatus under and a sort
of legal map and in some countries there
was a regional division as it happened
for instance a in venezuela and in this
phase that i would say it runs from the
1960s 1970s perhaps in brazil was
earlier it started in the 1950s with a
father joseph labrats visits ok but in
concerts probably like a medium-sized
countries like Venezuela Colombia etc
was a process of the 19
this was very much influenced by people
like the bread but also by the famous
theory of Francois Peru which in fact
was pretty much presence in it present
in the development of of sadhana so
these process from the 1960s to the
1970s was yes and a process supported by
an institutional apparatus and the
development of regional corporations and
I think that by the late 1970s the
regional apparatus was very much on it
was was started to be dismantled in some
cases okay just a somatic somatic can
note you know because it is much smaller
scale but I think that maybe what what
we've seen today may think of which
region region regional division I can't
even say this very general man's a shin
is sort of a preventive or corrective
against regionalism in a sense of
originalism may be destructive that
which the spontaneous developments you
know the and and the bureaucratic sort
of subdivisions is an attempt to pre pre
think of premeditate and pre-plan and
prevent this kind of local developments
but as we see you know it doesn't always
work you know in the end you know in
reality we have always do to consider
the dialectics between the the original
regionalist critical or not this because
we're here in Colombia after that Israel
is an interesting case of uncritical
regionalism if anything you know this is
yeah this should be the good that should
have been the death of my lecture maybe
yeah question is for V and again i'm
trying to think about scale again in
that transition from one scale to the
other as wondering whether in that
process of moving from the controlled
environment of the museum and the
production of a relatively small scale
of museum building to the national
larger scale of the state what happens
in that transition and what opportunity
for critical thinking takes place then
because for example we know that Alyosha
loans nightmare came true and israel's
eighty percent of israel's population is
concentrated along the coastal plain we
know for example that the development
tons of their new towns became a
colossal a colossal failure there are
nothing of homogeneous at no national
dreams they are nightmares interesting
that you mentioned because you know that
also mas was a nightmare came true the
museum grew up you know as i said is i
mentioned ten times the size that it it
was originally designed the nightmare is
even bigger because my office is
involved in this project that you've
seen we are now as their only of history
or the irony of this Torian you know
that we end up trying to deal with this
is kind of thinking no no of course of
course it's not it's not really the
example of the museum is not really it's
not really a critical troop to deal with
the planet visible but I was trying
because I had you know 20 minute a
framework I was trying to make a single
point and try to see if I can if we can
see the same kind of disorder
you know that I called borderline so do
you know this attempt to not deal with
what the object and with territorial
constraints and with boundaries if we
can talk about it through the exam of
the museum as if you want sort of
structural from image or even even
metaphor in order to explain the largest
scale phenomenon in Israel it's just I
think it's really important to tread
that transition really carefully because
exactly it runs the risk of presenting a
monolithic picture of State apparatuses
which several speakers have throughout
these two days warned against and
against it's important to understand
exactly the gap between the imagination
of architectural and planning
imagination and the practices that
happen and in that gap you know first
you may disagree with my argument but
the first we're dealing here with the
50s 60s and then the monolithic state
apparatus in the 50s is exactly
something to be talked about if you
think that that of course today you know
for the partner we see that the patterns
of of organization and settlement or
against the grain of the original plan
but we're describing what happened or
the ideas intentions link for structural
layout of the state and in a sense we
still see the same the same post the
same the same the same effort come from
above to inhabit the periphery if we
have to characterize Israel today as
well we can say that it's
peripheral mentality or what I call
provincial mentality to this very day
even if the spontaneous patterns of
organization are indeed as they as they
feared you know along the coast but
still you know what would be considered
as good practice you know in Israel
today is to go to the periphery right
you know that that's what that's what we
do not not you and me perhaps but that's
what what is what is planned today
that's what Israelis are doing that's
what we be considered pioneering to go
to to inhabit the periphery
yeah I think that because we are running
late and we're about to wrap this thing
up we're going to go on directly to the
next panel as soon as we sort up some
technical issues just bear in mind that
there is wine at the end of the tunnel
so I think we can all survive one more
that way we'll have more time for
discussion in and round table after
we're done so stay
you